[Music]
hi everyone so we are back
with the insane in the endgame and this
time i'm going to talk with you and show
you some games which go straight from
the opening
into the end game and there are quite a
few opening lights like in
this type of
opening lights and of course the first
one we remember
is the famous berlin wall which cost as
part of his world title no because he
couldn't break the berlin wall against
in the famous match against mir kramnik
but it's not of course the only line so
lately i've seen there are quite a few
alliance but let me show just one
example so lately i've seen against the
cow con and even uh maxim bashara graf
playing e4 c6 knight f3
d5 and now d3 and there are quite a few
players which play this one offering a
quite new solid end game for black like
d take on e4 and then queen take on d1
especially i liked when i saw this line
and played you know in in this line you
offer
a very normal end game for black and
like you're saying okay i'm going to
play better descent game and in in other
version if black does not want this end
game i saw one player i think it was
online guy when played i completely
opened a very sharp line so here after
bishop g4 he played h3 and bishop here
g4 and bishop jesuic and here i've seen
players play like queenie two knights
three but he played h4
so completely the opposite of what was
on the third move offering an endgame so
so let's take a look at and here the
idea of course if you take on e4 to give
up some material but especially to
you know to get a very active position
so let's take a look at this type of
game and i'm going to use the first game
we're going to watch is
also you know played at the end of the
previous year 2020
uh the dutch grand master lami against
grand master smirnoff and it was tata
still which quite curiously
this year in 2022 lammy played the same
position
and almost identical end game this time
with black i'm going to show you both of
this game because it's quite curious and
of course we have some other examples a
really
special you know uh chess players but
let's follow it with the opening of this
game d4 lammies with white smearing off
with black and they had when they played
this game very similar rating swami was
2606 asmr of 2604 so d4 d5 the very
solid slab defense c4
c6 knight f3 knight f6 e3 now of course
black usually chooses bishop f5 for
bishop g4 now black played bishop g4
queen b3 queen b6 and you can guess that
we are heading straight into the end
game
i don't know if you're going to get
insane in the end game but we're going
to have an end game immediately well
this end game is going to be quite you
know interesting so we may say that it's
just you know what we've said insane in
the end game so 95
centralizing the knight and attacking
the bishop
bishop f5 and now take on d5
so
white is getting patient with more space
but their pawn structure is not going to
be perfect which of course can be set
about black black has a very solid pawn
structure
very close to product but they have less
space now they exchange on b3 so we have
dimension post structure and they
capture with a piece on d5 your first
question may be why they take with a
piece on d5 well
i think my opinion is that they don't
capture with a pawn because they
give white more access to squares on the
queen side and especially the square b5
and you can see just one example this in
the line knight c3 and knight six
bishop d2 and when i try to get active
this is like a cellular activity because
i can play a roke4
and then i can use the b5 square no so
that's why they capture with a knight
and this of course
you know gives less control of the
center so black is solid but obviously
has less space because he has not
captured with the pawn which controls
central squares knight take on d5 and
now in this game larry played bishop d3
well he believed that this end game is
quite solid for black if he played the
same line like three days ago so now we
had january 18 the fourth round and the
steel 2022 and he played in the first
round in the b tournament and he was
with black let's first take a look at
this very very recent game played like
three days ago and lamy
the hero of our end game in the game we
are looking at and played at the end of
2020. now he is playing the same
position with black
quite interesting no now his opponent
played knight and three his opponent
he's a very young at the end of the game
i'm going to tell you dutch
player no not dutch player danish player
and his name probably i'm not going to
pronounce well i'm going to tell him at
the end of the game so 93
97
here for example black needs to exchange
more minor pieces the vision becomes
more solid because the lack of space is
going to be felt less so knight take on
d7
bishop take on d7 knight c4
and lami here played e6 of course it
doesn't make much sense here to play
knight before because aurora goes to a5
and you can never touch the b pawn
because this pin along the a file so
knight c4 e6 bishop d2
so just like what we've commented
white has more space but black relies on
his solid and quite compact pawn
structure
now bishop e7 by lamy when he played the
same game with black i repeat of course
night before still in my opinion he's a
little bit premature because it's going
to be followed by the same rook a5 so i
don't see much the point of playing
knight before bishop e7
bishop e2
castle
castle white rook fd8 we are following
with some quite easy to explain move
rook c1
bishop e8 it this person quite reminds
me it's a very interesting analogy you
know the cambridge springs variation but
without the quinx on the boat and this
was heavily played in the one of the
most famous world championship matches
between
the great jose ruka blanca and alexander
lekkin in buenos aires 1927. this type
of vision but of course
white pawns on the queen side were not
doubled so they had better pawn
structure and we had queens on the ball
but you have to see that black pressure
is quite solid but it's lacking space
so it's like a very near you know margin
between being solid and getting into a
real passive position so you have to be
careful about even in the end game no of
course knight a5
rook d7
bishop f3
and in my opinion here it was quite
interesting to start with f6 covering
the e5 square and keeping the
possibility of this bishop
later to be activated by the square g6
after knight c4 for example here you can
step back and if you place let's say e4
the knight
is getting maybe for his premature but
just to show you knight c7 and the
knight using his good pawn touch you can
jump to the b5 square black is very
solid here now the bishop can always go
to f7 to g6
but in this game lamy played rook c8
knight c4 b6
on 95 he has prepared just to play route
7 and everything is defended so his
opponent here played e4
you know trying to gain the space and
then there came in precision by allah he
played knight f6 and here in my opinion
night before he's a clearly better
alternative but he played knight f6
and bishop e3
and c5
now it's interesting that he his
opponent who at the end was victorious
in this game this young very promising
player
played d5
so he was playing you know to gain
material material like it happened in
the game but it was much more unpleasant
here to play d take on c5 relying
on you know questions which has to do
with the pawn strikes if he takes d take
on c5 black has a rather unpleasant
choice if he captures with the pawn rook
a5 then of course now black pawn
structure is far from perfect and white
has a clear strategic initiative and the
knight on f6 is not like the most active
piece which can be said basically about
most of the black minor pieces if he
captures with the bishop
then we play e5
now the e5
gains control of square d6 and it uses
the temporary pin along the c vowel
because if you try here to capture first
on e3
like like that then we're going to
capture knight take on e3 and you have
to exchange on c1 because two of your
pieces are under attack and you lose
control
of the t foul in this endgame just to
show you knight d5
bishop take on d5 knight
f5 is a very in my opinion very gloomy
one for black i mean if the knight goes
to d4 you have like a technically the
lost end game in my opinion and if you
go d4 still white plays rook jade king
f8 knight d6 and then
they just play f4 bring the king also
looks i mean losing in my opinion for
black if they have played 95 and without
his changing on e3 and then
still using the already mentioned pin
along the t file we have time to play 96
very important and then of course in
this vision you can see very clearly
that we are having an extra pawn and
slim chances here in my opinion for
black to survive this end game so this
was like a mission opportunity by the
white player
and but also it become you know gave us
and gives us a chance to look at one
interesting end game so here white play
diva
making like a passport every line that
if you capture twice from d5 they're
going to win an exchange but let's not
forget that black is keeping in this
case what happened in the game a perfect
pawn structure
pawn for the exchange and a pair of
bishop so basically you can be worse
so i think that here clearly they
underestimated
why the chance of the appointment they
captured on d5 lumi capstone d5 pawn
takes from d5 and now knight take on d5
it's going to be a gross mistake to play
like
d8 here because it allows
95 and then in the same line white is
going to get active pieces just to show
the difference let's say here you
capture on d5 let rook take on d5 bishop
take on d5 of course you can capture
with the knight because the pawn is
already hanging on a7 when you capture
rook take on d5 at least attacking the
white knight the knight is going here
knight c4 you have to defend the pawn
it's not so easy no you can't push it
forward because when b6 is hanging when
you go back you start winning time by
putting drugs on the open fire
then rook g7 bishop f4 or b7
96 another attempt so clearly on worst
version now you're going to compare it
in the game in the game alami took in my
opinion quite easily the right decision
knight take on d5 and he's getting a
very comfortable end game bishop g4 rook
g7 capturing on d7 bishop taken d7
compact ball structure which can be said
about the white one you know the double
b pawns here is quite sad a pair bishop
and a pawn for the exchange so
black cannot be rushed not even in their
dreams and they are the only ones who
can
you know put some pressure and this is
what they did take a look at the game
now white played bishop d2 oh if they
play rook d1 probably the same move is
going to follow bishop b6 so they played
bishop d2
bishop b6 rook d1 h5 gaining space
especially when you have more minor
piece and it's very important to have
better control of space and not to allow
drugs any activity on the open thumbs no
so try to limit the action h5
bishop p1
k7
f3 h4 very logical no you don't want the
bishop to appear on g3 oh let's forget
about that rook d3
bishop f6
bishop f2 well on f2 it's not the same
like being on g3 no where he feels very
much alive night before
the knight is coming to a central square
d4 everything looks very logical
king h1 but that's why chess is a very
complex game now you're going to see g5
and rookie one
knight d4 looks like
clearly
black is having the strategic initiative
bishop take on d4 and bishop take on d4
and here probably at the end of the
first time control
i don't know that's for sure but
probably lanny was having some kind of a
you know time trouble because after 96
he couldn't find a good answer to the
threat knight b5 so it's not so easy
first of all if you capture the pawn
like the pawn b3 then knight b5 becomes
quite real and after this move we can
play even first this intermediate move
and then capture on d4 and play
rook d3 you play b
bishop c4 of course then we're going to
have rookie 4. so
not very good idea to capture the pawn
also of course it's not a very good idea
to play a6 because what's going to
follow is b4
in the game probably lamin just made the
blunder here because what he has to find
here is there any square for the bishop
where there will be no
the typical nightfall well on f6 on g7
always follows 98.
so the only square here if he had
probably enough time now if he was fully
concentrated would have been bishop h8
now there is no light fork and of course
black continues to be the only side who
can play for a win in this end game
now you can see how crotch has can be in
what followed in the game because in the
game alami played quite carelessly a5
and now knight b5
rook c6 knight acon d4
king g1 capturing on b through capturing
on default the vision has changed a lot
and now the rooks are active and white
showed a very good technique
and very concrete play and because
probably there was some other ways to
play technically but they played in a
very concrete way which probably is now
quite typical of this young and very
talented player
quite even in a technical phase their
play looks quite like a computer so it
has this influence no so let me show you
how this game ended which probably was
quite sad for nalami so bishop e6 rookie
two covering the second one king g6 h3
preparing f4 and then of course the rook
is going to gain a lot of power and the
pawn h4 is going to fall and then you
don't need some kind of exceptional
technique
rook c5 f4 rugby five capturing here
obviously the pawn h4 is not going to
survive for a long time because now we
are threatening to change rook if the
rook stays changed then the end game is
super easy you know because
most of the black pawns are going to be
eaten
you know
each each spawn
every second which is not a good thing
so they keep the rook but it's going to
cause the material now they don't have
even a pawn you know for the exchange so
you've got to show some technique okay
for the most you know
concrete you know realization of that
time the rook stays here
covering you know the fourth rank but
most importantly keeping the pawn at b6
it cannot down because i'm going to
capture an a5
so many players probably me too will be
a little bit doubtful to keep the look
at such a strange position
but the young danish
grandmaster i guess
had no problems you know to play it like
that and then he won the game let me
show the end of this game g4 kg7 h4 durk
on the fourth rank is quite useful to be
honest now you play b5 to exchange the a
pawn for the g pawn still the rooks have
a lot of space you see and then the king
may have obvious problems the black king
i mean the white king is not going to
get
never problem because he can always use
the dark squares because there is nobody
who can do anything to him on the dark
squares because the bishop is a light
squared bishop so the end of this game
black tried to activate the king but the
rooks prevail which is no big surprise
here
group b4 now if you take the pawn
g6
here for example is not the right moment
because i can capture and if you capture
back the pawn b2 is hanging but why
would first prepare that with this move
okay one moment rook a6 and then g6
you can play like bishop f5 because
you're going to get checkmated by the
rolling stream team rook h6
and
yes
so
in the game what followed this before
king g1 and the rest was in my opinion
quite easy because the white rook
display and the maximum activity
they have a lot of open files so this is
the game
biere probably i can't pronounce right
you know
the right danish pronunciation
his rating now is 2586 born in 2004 so
you can make the count probably you know
he's like 17 years old and he's going to
accomplish this year 18. now his
opponent lami was born in 1985. he still
is in a very good chess age but you see
that white displayed in this game when
they had real prompt more energy which
is an important part of playing chess
and especially the end games now let's
back
and get back to our end game when lamy
like ania and a little bit more ago he
had the white piece he had played here
bishop d3 of course black he exchanged
from d3 now
they don't have any other alternative if
they play e6 they have to part with the
pair of bishop which
you see in many accounts is not a very
good idea oh
they have you know pros because of this
pin along the eighth house let me show
you this with simple lines so i need to
play e6 e4 is going to follow and knight
b4 is not going to help a lot no because
we take on f5 and when we play f6 and we
keep the pair of bishops and i don't
like the black pigeon it doesn't mean
that it's like a lost one but i don't
like when the piston is open and the
opponent is having pair bishops quite
logical you know
and f6 here
tactically does not work because white
plays knight c4 and when the knight goes
this knight from d5 the square b6 is
going to cost
black material because of the pin along
the a file
okay i can show you but
the idea is quite clear no knight b6
so bishop taken d3 knight take on d3
and now
black played 96 so here i want to show
one example in the whole game then i'm
going to show you one example of a
recent very good young players but not
the whole game but this game in my
opinion deserves to be shown the whole
one because it's an end game by one of
the greatest women chess talent and it's
i mean a player i've always you know
thought it's like exceptional this is
the ex-world champion
maiachi berninsi so she was born in 1961
but she kept the world title for 14
years and she had like something
exceptional chess talent you could see
that because she is known for a lot of
you know checkmating attacks an
incredible you know feel for the
initiative in chess but also her end
game technique was something you know
very very special so you can see
this technique in a game where she
played against a solid
strong uh women and grandmaster from
armenia
and she is like i think 17 years younger
than her but still the technique of
chimpanzees was exceptional so here her
opponent played e6 and she
showed the typical plan
bishop d2
k2 you put the king in the center of
castle
93 96 the first impression is that
not an obvious plan here for white they
have more space but black is very solid
so let's see knight c4
knight before knight e5 the first quite
logical moment you avoid exchanges
because if you want to exploit an
advantage space you don't want to
exchange pieces if you change pieces the
long term factors are going to be you
know more important so what are the long
term factors that one side black has a
better pawn touch the other who has more
space with exchange pieces
the side with less space which are black
they're not going to have many problems
to put their piece because they don't
they are not going to have many pieces
so this is the logic behind avoiding
change so knight e5 by chiber denis
rook d8 rook c1
well usually we allocate the rooks on a
half open or open five is quite logical
f6
knight f3
now the first weak spot has been already
created then this is not easy to be spot
but this is on the king side and she
starts with this typical play first
avoid exchange put the knight on a more
active pistol because you can compare
knight a5 and knight b6 obviously one of
them is more active and we actually
plays rook d7 g4
and now he wants to weaken and
especially the dark squares on the king
side and
the problem here for black that they are
solid but they don't have any real
counter play no because of the lack of
space
so
and the pawns the b pawns along the the
double b balls i mean the white pigeon
keep the rooks active along the a and
the c file and prevent any counter play
so dislike the benefit of this pause
well if peace exchange they can be a
problem but now they are not you know
such a glaring problem because you can't
get to them so g4 key f7 g5 of course
not mentioning you can capture on g5 and
mr4 on e5 no and then probably like
they've taught in my country if you miss
such details you have to take like a
break of chess of like
like a year and a half or something like
that no if you start missing details
like this one this of course is a joke
but
this was a famous phrase so rook v8
e4
the advantage space is becoming
bigger and you take away the d5 square
the play of triple engine is like an
example king eight
capturing on a6 knight c4 now her point
here captured on c4 and made white pawn
structure not to be a problem for the
whole game
but even if they play the better option
in my opinion knight c8 the steel white
is quite active and we already have some
problems on the king's side so her play
was really very good but still my take
on c4 is not a decision
we should be happy about now of course
she takes with a pawn
now
somebody said something about you know
structural promise because i don't see
any no of course now we don't have any
problems with the pawn structure
it's a rather compact one
white has two pawn island because
b c d e f are one island and the ice h
well
black has three pawn island so now they
have respawn structure so this is one of
the benefits that i have achieved
knight a6 of course this knight
is not a very active piece that's for
sure rk5 activating the rook c5 d5
it's not a coincidence such a great
player to bring it now by chance i'm
joking put the pawn on a light squares
so king f7 having a dark square bishop
rook a1 keeping you know this knight
quite passive capturing on d5 capturing
we can see the problem is it it's very
hard here to offer something for black
they just have to be in a waiting move
rook eight and bishop e3 defending the
central pawn and of course preparing a
night future on the square c4 for
example no
f5
you can't capture the pawn no because
there is through quechua
so the small tactics always a sign of
your good technique but you have to be
able
now let me
make this important note in my opinion
so a very big part of your end game
technique is very precise calculation of
short lines
so some may think for example let's take
players which also like are already you
know relatively quite you know on an
advanced age and they say for example
natalikarp who is not an active player
anymore well he doesn't have you know
the technique he used to have well it's
better to be
said like that he doesn't have the same
nervous system which does not allow him
with this precision to calculate the
short lines he have the same technique
but he doesn't have you know this
concentration and this
super solid nervous system which allows
you to be like a machine calculating
short lines when you are very good at
the short lines this makes everything to
go smoothly this makes your technique
chest technique very good when you start
making these small mistakes in the short
lines then you give the impression like
yeah
this technique is not what it used to be
so it's this detail which is very
important so 92
f5
f3
knight before well here black started
losing their pension because they're in
a very passive position and they wanted
some activity and it's not
something you can see in the women chest
you can see in all types of chest it's
not you know typical for us humans just
to stay passively even if she has played
bishop c7 this patient looks you know
not
a patient you'll be very happy because
still the knight on c7 looks a very
sad piece but after night before the end
came
quite you know fast and still
even till the end she brings not not
only showed the good technique but she's
a chess artist you're going to see the
finish of this game so rook take on a7
now you can close the rook no with 96
because i'm going to capture with the
rook from a1 there is a pin along the
seven right so they try
to
get the rook out of the afoul rook f1
check rook f5 activating the piece now
they try to close this rook but it's not
going to last forever and bishop f4
bishop f4 is quite logical not only
changing the bishop but preventing you
know bishop b8 just in case no not to
have the prisoner there so bishop f4
and of course
making the path of the balls a very near
future the pawns of dn because they're
you know connected past pawns in the
center so
it's hard to imagine any other result
that white winning here so king g7
kf3
knight b4 knight c4 knight e3 and now a
nice typical very precise finish of
chipotle ninja what a sign of a great
player 96 with a tempo
because okay the more piece they change
the more you can just the position is
completely resignable because the pawn
just and go you know without any
you know brain power jesus go by the
hand so
95 check keto knight g6
he captured here caption b7 king a6 and
what i meant by artistic here of course
many moves were possible but she played
just
e3 here her opponent could have resigned
she continued for a couple of moves but
of course nobody can stop such pawns
if you play here and you just advance in
your car i know everybody knows about
the bridge in chess
the rook bridge so rook f2 d6 d7 and
here her point resign this was played in
year 2010
so she brings it she made like long pass
in chess but still you see the great
talent of some chess player it's still
there you can see you know
it can be hidden no in this game it is
clearly on everybody to see
so let's continue with our
game so after 96
this was the move that was played in our
game not e6 but the pistons are very
similar so knight e6 bishop d2 e6 ke2
now
black played bishop e7 there is some
problems here with with knight before
i mean
with knight before this is like not a
bad move but it has been played in one
game of young players and although black
got like a solid position so i think the
the
what i wanted to tell it after king e2
on f6 there were some after night to
night before there was some
tactical handicaps but also this country
let me first show you on the
conversation in the game of this penguin
knight before
although a logical one
still
after that the end game
the plan which you saw in the game of
chief britain is a very typical one so
still
black has this problem finding like a
real counter play so i'm not going to
show the whole game but you're going to
see a lot of similarities in the game
esipenko
now quite a famous grand master
with
rating 2714 and born 2002 so you can
imagine that he's quite young against a
grandmaster i've never heard but he's
born in 1997 basel with rating 2600.
well the fact that i don't know him
doesn't matter at all but still a young
player so in this game after 93 black
played a6 knight c4 f6n follows the
typical plan advancing and gaining space
and trying to create weaknesses on the
king side well
this is quite natural because this is
the white's playground they can play on
the queenside when they have this pawn
structure
so they have to create
weaknesses on the king side and maybe
provide some additional you know
problems for black or some availability
of other squares like the square e5
so h4 g5
f5
rook g1 castle rook a4 the knight has to
step back well b5 here i don't like that
oh this of course because it's bad
knight d5
and after 95
still the position looks solid for black
but the lack of countably starts
becoming a little bit alarming and
here white is gaining more space and
then they you know played e4 and they
really got
finally a real advantage and their
bishop together with more space turn out
to be the better minor piece and every
rook and game here is problematic just
because this lack of space
and the advance of the pawn on the king
side remind me some games of like in
this typical end games we're not going
to see the whole game but also want to
show that the vision needs really
precise blade from black and to be
really familiar what they are doing now
what i promised you with f6
93 and now you play knight before there
are some tricks for white tactical
tricks like knight take on b4 and if you
take with the bishop knight c4 and you
have after capturing here this
intermediate move 96 this is one of the
problems when you play here this rocket
game
which is possible because of this move
no trapping division is a real problem
the white hooks are much more active
than the black rooks and of course you
are playing only for tourism i mean
black has to fight for a joint quite
you know unpleasant end game the same
team can be spotted if they play like k7
here and then rook take on a6 a similar
end game like this one here and i still
don't like it like if it's going to be
decent game
i don't like it so that's why
here in our game
black played a solid move bishop e7 in
my opinion
uh normal one knight e3
castle knight c4 and here very early in
the game and they lost
you know their patience and they played
a move in which in my opinion they
should have seen the idea the idea is
just on the surface then of course white
played a very good game
by the way they get a very you know
comfortable position they basically was
very difficult for them to go wrong they
still produce
an end game joe a great play but t5 here
you have to look at the very
natural exchange sacrifice what do
sheikh what they should have played well
knight before or even first rook fb8
prophylactic and white has more space
like we've seen a couple of good end
games but like a solid though does not
mean that you know they have like a bad
position but after t5 we can say that
they really starting having a clearly
bad end game so maybe they just miss
this obvious rook take on a6 exchange
sacrifice because they are looking like
d take on c5 here of course black has no
problem whatsoever it's it's clear on
the road no or e4 knight f6
still we can't see in creating any
problems here for black but after move
through k6 take a look at this vision
and then i capture on c5 so i'm
controlling the queen side i'm going to
uh
support my pawn on c5 with the b4 i have
the rook on the a file so
here what can happen i mean black is
facing a very tough defense and
basically no count to play for the rest
of the game
so how they missed that
probably only smilov can explain the
player with black in this game after you
play here rook b8 b4
the same position like it happened in
the game they played rook g8
b4
f6 e4 gaining more space now of course
knight b6 we're going to play the
national 95 because we avoid exchanging
especially when we have such a
domination no like knight e4 rook c1
looks you know quite bad now if you play
knight d7 or k1 also not looking quite
bad so here
knight c7 was played in the game at
least the knight wants to defend the
pawn a6 you know and maybe sometimes use
the b5 square but white continues with a
very natural fashion bishop c3 here or
k1 the promise is no matter when you
exchange one of the white minor pieces
the their pawn structure becomes even
more unpleasant for the opponent
and this weakness is along the eighth
out there basically forever to stay
look c6 and then e5 this is a good move
because it wins more space and provides
an excellent outpost on d6
and it's like a very good outpost
because nobody can get you and if you
take on d6 then the pawns basically are
one step away from becoming you know
from getting their dream which is the
promotion now f5 here
is not good because after 96 i mean we
follow it knight b3 and then 95 it looks
also very difficult pission well this is
even worse i'm not taking on e5 because
then you lose immediately upon a6 and
then you get nothing in return so black
played bishop d8
96
rook b8 here i've given one example if
you take on dc all the efficient looks
so bad
probably it's not even needed but let me
give you one idea how white is going to
try to exploit the great
uh special edge and the fact that the
opponent basically can
only move on the background and wait to
see if white is going to fight like
one of the many planes to improve their
vision one of them is for example h3 k3
centralizing the king
g4 trying to create you know a wider
front when you
when you this one very standard
technique you provide when you have more
space you try to create
more than one weak spot in the point
pitch on a because you have
uh more space you can
maneuver your pieces much easily and
then finally he has problems you know to
be able to defend this weak spotting his
mission so here g4 anyway he captures
then he opens file for your rook
because okay dork is not going to stay
on a1 attacking on asic when he's
defending by luke now he can infiltrate
along the h file
now black in our end game played rook b8
f4
h5 g3 97 and now the king comes to
support the keys came to square c4
and checks with the knight he's not
going to change anything because
everything is completely defended no and
like i've told you any exchange of the
minor piece makes
even more threatening white pawn
structure which now this bishop on d8
i don't know
if it needs to be called the bishop no
he pretends to be a bishop but actually
not
so ke3 f5 well copy that maybe you know
blocking depiction is going to help
but it's hard to imagine when the
opponents have a pair of knights the
cavalry
they really you know
try to have you know close vision
because they can do whatever they want
bishop d2
king f8 king d4 g6 and now the knight
goes
into a better position the knight from
d3 now he have various you know
natural route he can go e1 f3 d4 or e1 c
to d4 and the king of course is going to
go to t4 and then something is going to
fall in the black pieces and when the
first you know
pawn falls
more space for white
more
freedom for their opponent so probably
it's going to be like an avalanche
something like that happen in the game
in a very nice manner
91
knight b5 czech well if they play king
e7 i've already explained the ideas
they're quite natural so knight b5 check
knight take on b5 if you capture
with the rook then knight f3 and the
knight goes to
d4 okay you can give back some material
by the way here you can hope that some
miracle is going to happen because
i mean
the material is bad bottom white is
controlling all type of squares having a
knight and a bishop and the rooks i mean
quite pathetic in my opinion so
capturing with opponent b5 rook take on
a7 here of course they hope that you
know only a miracle probably can save
them but at least there was something
practical when they captured with the
pawn
finally the rooks which were like
buzzing at the back of the black piston
absolutely mean
lacking any kind of active play now they
have one open file which will be the a
file and maybe they'll try to force the
white rook to be exchanged and at least
this is what they hope so rook c8 knight
c2 noto k8 rook d7 keeping the active
piece bishop p7 there is no point to
play here king eight because they're
going to play rook g7 and keep gobbling
up all the black the black pawns bishop
p7 preventing look to go further
king e3
king eight and now
maybe some players will play here rook
b7 and
thinking that this end game probably is
also quite bad for black this one i
think is bad but maybe this one
at least give them some you know hope
for some activity they can give up some
material but activate the piece
objectively probably it's also bad but
the decision of huami shows really a
good player a very good player because
here he thought okay i'm not going to
give any counter player going to even
sacrifice some material but then the
domination of my piece and the pawn
avalanche is clearly you know
sweeping every everything you know which
tries to get in front of their way and
he played rook d6 a second exchange
secretary but this time
the white pawns are rolling in a very
natural way
bishop takes on d6 well he was starting
to play knight d4 so you don't have much
of a choice you have to capture
pawn of course captures from d6 e pawn
and king descend now we have this total
domination and after 92 the white found
an easy way you know to bring the
victory home ru k2 the knight is getting
knight f395 you can't do anything
against it and they are too much
passport in my opinion
k2
bishop c3 these two minor pieces not
only are defending everything but it's
helping the pawns to go forward
rook a1
knight b5 i mean if you defend the pawn
with b8 knight f3 and so you can defend
all the pawns because i mean
you don't have operating you know room
for your rooks and there are too many
past pawns and
the white two minor pieces are really
doing whatever they want
so here knight take on b5 now we're
going to have a lot of pass pawns
key f2 not giving not even a single pawn
knight d4
rk k2 the king is feeling for yourself
very well if you play like rook a1 and
the pawn starts rolling everything is
defended so you can create not even a
single threat and this pawns
very easily are going to move i'm going
to play bishop b4 in the later on or
here for example if you don't just wait
i'm going to play knight 395 if you move
the rock from d1 bishop b4 c6
so
rook g1
b5
the g pawn is not so important and when
the pawns are moving check king d3 rugby
toe
and seasick check
and after knight taken easy here black
resigned because you can't stop so many
pawns they're incredibly strong no the
finish could have been something like
that here
check and
this is the end because this check is
the final check the checkmate so in my
opinion
quite a good game by lami and then also
a very good you know end game
performance a very good endgame
performance i also saw very recently and
it's a very good game
we have time to show it to you i'm going
to miss some line but i hope you're
going to enjoy it so this is the game
okay let me go to the next one
this is quite the famous game the game
between corona and furugen
on this famous grand trees in riga where
philosopher was leading all the time but
he lost in a penultimate round still
he's such a
incredible young chess talented he was
able to win the tournament at the last
round and to classify for the candidates
in the next candidates no but the game
was a quite an interesting one so carl
was with white he played e4 c6d for d5
and then he chose the advanced variation
now this is quite popular
uh we see very often that for example
mark the world champion magnus carson is
using quite a bit of task ideas to try
to you know to play
some interesting sharp position
in many lives i've seen that he likes
tao's idea here one of them which he
used against norwich
this was the second part of the 2020 was
in the gambit line of the
karo khan the advanced version of c5 he
played this old thousand idea i think
taffy employed in the second match
against
uh but finnick in 1961 and this is the
idea queen g4 and he won a very good
game against nordic although it was
online chat but the game was quite good
so here firoge
plays
bishop f5 and the world champion plays
this mission his favorite lines to play
with t493 playing for space and he has
quite
a good example excuse the tao also in
his very years play this line then he
started to play different line he
started to also play here h4 which we're
going to see in our game so for example
h4
is a line which a player like corona
likes magnus khan tries you know to
start pushing the pawns a little bit
later he's a little bit more reluctant
you know to make pornography but
karana is a very aggressive player
like most of the very good players he
treasures a lot you know the advantage
space and he's not afraid to play
such a
line like with h4 here the handicapped
when you move the pawn on h4 and is
blocked by eight right there is no going
back so you're going to rely on play on
the dark squares on the light squares
it's very hard to imagine that something
positive is going to happen of course
i'm going to show there are some
exceptions no so h4h5 bishop d3 aligned
known from the famous game neem switch
against crablanca classical game which
neem switch played quite poorly we have
shabbat kablanker played quite well so
bishop d3 queen takes on d3 white have
more space but
black like always in this tracker is
quite solid
but sometimes like i've told you earlier
there is very you know slight margin
between solid and becoming passive so
queen a5 check 92
now
because we don't have so much time i
don't want just to mention that queen
a6k is not played immediately because it
allows e6 the following end game this
one in my opinion is just for two
results i would not like to play i've
seen some players good one playing it
but i don't like it
uh for black although i'm not like a
character specialist for sure so 92
e6
92 and now it has been played here queen
a6 after queen asic they usually play c4
also queen f3 is quite interesting
so but not let get so much into the
opening detail because here we are
talking about the end game and now
you're going to see that this line also
is going to provide like an immediate
you know transition from an opening
straight into an endgame so
97 and now corolla no surprise use b4
this is the first line of the engine and
the strategic idea behind this line is
to try to
put some pressure on the queen side and
the following end game is going to be
quite interesting now before of course
even like by the simple like it's not
good to capture on b4 because then rook
b1 rook take on b7
looks quite bad for black so just one
line here you capture here bishop a3
and okay if you want to lose the queen
it can be done very easily here okay one
so queen a6 and now queen b3 this is the
positional idea behind to try to use the
situation of the black queen of this
strike a relatively new positional idea
to try to you know use the attack of the
queen to win some time to expand on the
queen side black continues to be solid
but the end game has to be played quite
precisely knight t5
knight f3
knight d7 a4 and just at the right time
here future plays queen c4 why not later
because if you played bishop e7 white
have time to play c3 and after queen civ
to exchange into play a5
here you have
obvious problems with space and no
counter play to be seen so that's why we
play queen c4 here because if you
exchange noun c4 the pawn
on b4 is under attack then you have time
then to play a5 or if you defend it for
example bishop d2 to play knight b6 and
knight d5
on b5 of course we're going to react
with c5 so
this explains why caruana plays bishop
d2 and he prepares
to exchange squeeze and to play a5
black cannot allow such a luxury so
that's why they take on b3 now white's
pawn structure is far from perfect but
black counter play the only one which is
visible is to try to play c5 and it's
not easy here to prepare t5 although
they did all the best now in my opinion
the next move
is a typical example and you're going to
see that the end game is going to be
quite complex there will be some rare
exception and even the best chess
players when they
you know
encounter such very rare exceptions can
make mistakes this is normal especially
in time travel so here is one of these
light examples here wanting you to get
some more activity
villager played f6
and usually you know the base strategic
advice is not to play on the flank where
the opponent is stronger so although f6
looks like not a bad move i think it was
strategically better to play bishop e7
and then to try to prepare c5
so it looks to me kind of more natural
the way
fiji is a great player of course much
longer
than us he taught f6 but let's see what
happened after f6 carolina castled
bishop e7 g3 king f7 rookie one and now
he took an e5 you may wonder why he took
on e5 well if he done and say where is
the counter play how you're going to be
able to
push c5 if you don't take on e5 so he's
not very happy to take on e5 and tweak
in the g5 square but there was no other
way to seek for some you know active
play so this is the reason behind
capturing on e5
pawn take on e5 now you have to use you
know the g5 square but of course there
is one defender of this square which is
the bishop e7 so you try to neutralize
this defender if you play here at c5
immediately which is what
black is striving to do so technically
white is going to play knight f4 with
the tempo threatening knight d5 and when
you play d4 he's going to capture here
and try to activate his piece here we
can look at a lot of you know lines and
let me show you just one and if you
capture the pawn and then immediately
the rooks are getting active
like that
and this is something
which black should should avoid so here
for example the rook on the third rank
is coming to f3 and the the king feels
really difficult
and the knight
is starting to have in domination over
the bishop why this is happening because
the fight is in a smaller area and the
knight is more useful if the range was a
factor and then it's going to be
different
so
here's a plate rook t8
knight f4
d4
of course not c5 because of knight take
on d5 no d4 rook c1 and now black has
less space and needs to play t5 if not
he's going to be left without any active
play c5 knight d5 well here for example
the computer was showing some ideas with
rook t4 which look quite
extraterrestrial maybe they are good but
we humans play in a more you know
our way so 95 has a very clear idea to
defend and to exchange the defender of
the square g5 and then of course the
king on f7 may have problems so this is
a very logical move and here
first played
a seemingly like he doesn't have many
alternatives but the idea he employed in
the game here there was like a better
execution of course it was quite you
know complex to see that first of all to
show that this of course is bad i mean
this is like
a very bad vision probably completely
lost captioning on b4 we're going to see
in the game
and bishop d6 looks passive to me like
this type of bishop in my opinion we can
look at it but just to show you one
interesting positional example if we
follow let's play some natural move i
take here then i activate the root i
give you opponent b3
because i want my rook to be active and
then i got a patient i have only the
knight and you have a bishop and a
knight but the king
is you know pin on the seventh leg so
here the knight clearly dominate
and
black will be happy to exchange these
two pawns even for the one white pawn
but they are not going to achieve it
this is a quite curious vision let me
show you a couple of moves let's
centralize the king here and i play a5
and after playing knight b3
it turns out that black are starting to
you know
to you know to miss like a useful move
just interesting example so in the game
they captured on b4 but the idea which
they employed in the game which could
have been avoided by corolla
here probably the best implementation
but a complex one was to play king g6
and to give up material
like knight take on e7 take on c5 take
care and to play knight five and in this
endgame of course black
most probably is worse but they have
some you know active play for the pawn
so this was an interesting idea when
they captured on b4
here caruana captured on e7 knight
takuni 7 and played a very natural
active conclusion which turns out not to
be the best one because it gave counter
play and the end game became very
interesting
maybe very very interesting because
after that you're going to see something
very
you know a lot of interesting events but
here
white could capture into a more
technical position they could have taken
on b4 which was objectively much better
than knight g5 and then
knight six is quite bad because then
you're going to lose the pawn d4 for
nothing no
that's for sure so we have to play
knight d5 and if you continue here like
bishop d6 d3 rook d1 rook g3 and white
has some ideas which are going to
help them in my opinion to go to an end
game with
good winning chains like knight g5
knight iconistics rook b3 it looks like
a force line but after knight f3
we have a clear plan to play rookie for
rook d4
and i thought that here black is having
some
big big problems in the end game i'm not
going to claim that white is winning but
this was a difficult question after 95
surprisingly
the great talent of eurozone finds a
great idea probably the only one he
plays 96 he gives up material but
activate his piece at the maximum knight
six now of course if you play knight
four the king goes further e69 c5
probably this type of lies
were like the constant have some future
mistakes what you're going to see
because here the activity of kim is very
natural and very important
now after knight six karana played f4 to
defend his central pawn and king f5 this
was the excellent idea by filter giving
up a second pawn but maximum activity
king g6
king f5 and now if you don't want to
foster jordan you have to allow
the black cavalry to become quite active
knight c5 the end game becomes
quite sharp
knight f7 in my opinion the only chance
to play for a win you play e6 i just
play rk8
and the pawn can be defended so
knight f7
king is 6
96
now rook j
of course some other moves are possible
but there is nothing more natural than
this move no rook j to attack the pawn
g3 so rook j8 and the king g2 it was
very hard to imagine here close to the
first time control and furuja and also
karambah feroza was in a
real time trouble says white is going to
play like a move for like f5 and even if
they found this idea which is possible
not on this move to find the only move
knight e4 it's not enough to have some
real winning chance
and it's a lot of calculation work so
take a look again f5 here in defending
the pawn 93
looks like a winning
triple attack attacking the rook the
pawnee five the b and now you fight 94
and even in the end of this line
we can say that
white is winning for sure so
corolla played the very logical king ji2
king d5
rook b1 and now we see the consequence
of time travel so here
firoge maybe because he was like the
leading entertainment became a reckless
little bit in his time travel and i
started to play a vision when the price
of the move became very high and when
you're in time travel this is a very
risky he could have played something
very solid here because obviously now he
has compensation for the material there
is no doubt about that so he could have
played here for example b6 or even the
most logical no just to defend the pawn
b4 with the pawn a5
then probably he didn't reason
he didn't risk much here no he would not
have lost this game but he thought okay
let's put the tension to the maximum and
this when you're in time travel you're
going to see what it led so 94
betting on the activity of the king but
this is one of these rare exception when
the activity of the king
is not really successful because there
are some other factors on the board
which are the passers the white central
passers and they're going to be some
real heroes so knight taken ifo king tay
kunifo rukshiwan continuing now with
activity king d3 beta was to play a5 but
okay he was in severe time travel so
let's not be critical and this was his
idea
so let's be objective so king d3
bishop p1 and he continues with king e2
of course nobody here is going to expect
the future played that to play king e4
what for example an engine is going to
offer this makes no sense at all this
was his original idea kingito
betting everything on the activity of
the king and in most of the case this is
the right idea no but in this one
it turns out that the activity of
certain force prevails so ke2 e6 now one
of the problems that you can just stop
them let's say here mechanically by
playing k7 because he's going to capture
on b4 and if you play a5 which is a very
important line white plays f5
rook 8 bishop f2 then start pushing the
balls check
and f6 and of course
not so surprising the white pawns are
faster so he had in mind d3 there is no
doubt in that
f5
knight d4
not much alternative here if you capture
here i take
and the pawns
promote
no surprise here rook 8 was something
very hard to see during a chess game and
still at the end on a long line it's not
working but it's very very hard to see
over the boat so let's go
with what happened originally in the
game because it's quite beautiful so
here
villager played knight before at the end
of the first time still in severe time
trouble
here's a point played bishop b4 and here
the main
okay not the main but one important
tactical tells if you can capture the
pawn a5 well probably both of the
opponents so because if you capture here
this is not just a check it's a
checkmate so sometimes you see the very
active king can have
even in the endgame some probes although
this is very rare so bishop b4
d2
bishop taken d2 and now rook c5 the best
way to support the bot and of course
this move is quite easy because it
defend the pawn
f5 and the rook goes to the optimal
square e5 and it also cuts away the
black king so now the black king turns
out not to be active but to be a little
bit you know too far away from the pawns
which becomes an essential factor what
we're going to do again this pawns
so future played rookie 8 rookie 5 and
now try to bring
this too far away king he played king d3
if you play knight 6
check
if you go to the e file
then rook d6 threatening of course f6
well if the king was close a little bit
but he's not like he tries to get closer
nobody stops the pawn
and okay here don't be surprised we've
seen
at least in some of our games this
happening though whether we were
you know
winning these games or losing by the way
this with the pawns is quite typical if
you play king c3 then of course you
can't hold it you're going to cope with
the balls with such a king now for
example we are already
ready to play f6 so no matter what black
plays let's say b5 f6 of course rook d6
is also quite good in my opinion winning
f6 or you can play a5 the same f6 f7 end
of the game
so after rookie 5 this was the idea that
he has to bring the king but like after
it's a little bit late so k3
kf2 this was a very good and a very easy
to understand human move what's behind
king f2 he wants to provide the square
e3 because if he tries to be impatient
and let's say g for capturing king g3
then knight f3 is kind of unpleasant no
i think he started taking the pawns with
king e4 the king he's just in time if
you play e7
then knight c6
now this is the moment
let me show that's why he played king f2
because he wants when you play knight
six okay for rookie three check now if
you play it immediately e7 after knight
six you don't have
square here no on the
e5 to give rookie three and to play in
f6 so you have to play in this check and
then
trying to be you know in computer like
style like on 97 to have this move but
this is not very human so corona played
an extremely good human move and now
he's putting the question to black what
is your useful move and it's really a
very good question because there is not
a good answer if you play let's say in
king c3
does not make much sense because the
king is getting again far away from the
pawns this can finish very well and of
course it doesn't no e7
this rocket game is completely lost i
mean no need to comment upon that
knight six for example
rook check an important win of time and
then capturing here
you have to take on e7 if not the pawns
become queen
and this rocket game i mean
nothing good can happen because in my
opinion you are missing a lot of tempos
if you play knight six immediately then
the idea which i which was prepared by
kerala rookie to recheck and the pawns
go forward here there'll be nothing you
can do because the pawns
go very very
easily forward so
what else he can do
so the other move knight sick i already
showed you so that's why he played
rookie 7 here
no other useful move could be seen in my
opinion
but now when the rook is on e7 it's very
close to the mind that sometimes white
is going to win tempo against this not
very fortunate situation of the rook on
e7
g4 just at the right moment also great
move because now knight six of course is
bad because there are too many pawns
going forward i mean this is a little
bit too much no f7 is threatening
and then g5 no
so you have to capture on g4 and now
a very important endgame warrior one of
the most famous the king he's joining
the rook and so now we're going to have
three past pawn
joint but all the white force and don't
be surprised that it's going to be
impossible to stop these pawns now
knight f3 f6
nothing to command
this rook end game is completely lost
because basically the h pawn becomes the
queen i mean everything is defended so
rookie
by furuj
king take on g4 here in my opinion
not even some practical chance i
couldn't find not even a single
practical change you play like king c3 i
mean how you're going to stop the pawn
they are moving in a very easy fashion
this was check no so winning time
that's why the king going to the
uh queen side always gives valuable time
to white so makes no sense at all
if you give this check also it's quite
hard to see what are you getting no you
can give another check of course knight
six
is completely hopeless not a pawn just
go forward this check also does not help
at all because the pawns are just
you know
very easy becoming new queen so he
played knight six and now of course
other moves were possible but kara
finished the game in the most elegant
way king f4
he doesn't care about giving even luke
but who can stop the pawns we already
know that with such king so far away
nobody can stop the pawn so king f4 very
human if you play king d4
rookier and the pawn starts going
forward now when you try to deal with
two pawns the h pawn is the other factor
not like the decisive
x factor let's say
h6 check and okay the pawns are going to
become after six the new queens so here
97 was played in the game well not
because he had a lot of shoes
f6
check well we've already seen it why
array to give up
now they give the h pawn but the knight
becomes too far away from the pawns and
everything becomes crystal clear knight
h4
was played
king g5
nightfall but when the knight frog is
not enough
you know this seems the end game has you
know
has really been a difficult one here
knight take
on e5 of course
i mean it's completely hopeless because
nobody can stop the pawns no and e7 he
played 94
e7 and knight six f7 and here of course
the pawn has become new queens and after
this intermediate check he resigned a
very in a very good game in a very tense
moment in the ninth round of the
tournament
corona was victorious but at the end
this
super young talent who is number two now
in the world chess rating
was you know classified for the next
candidate tournament and we're going to
see how he's going to do so i hope all
of you liked
this interesting and game examples
and
continue to work on the end game because
it's hard to imagine you can become a
good player without having like at least
decent endgame technique thank you again
and see you soon i guess
thank you bye
[Music]
you